yeah just in the last few minutes really
i mean you can see behind us this is one
of the main freight entrances into the
calais side of the euro tunnel usually
it's uh flowing freely but uh just in
the last half an hour or so convoy
several dozen vehicles uh and fishermen
have pulled up here
completely blocking both the entrance
and the exit you can just see there
they're trucks who were attempting to
leave the euro tunnel complex
but now cannot um and earlier today here
in calais we saw the fisherman's uh
protests escalate again when a fleet of
fishing vessels blockaded at the port
entrance here in calais for a number of
hours
that protest has moved on and now they
have uh blocked
using lorries the entrance to the
eurotone let's try and find out why uh
benoit furman
is one of the fisherman's
representatives here in northern france
benoit what is the point of this sort of
protest will it not just alienate public
support no i don't think it's
grandchildren it's public support we
have strong public support and what i
like about the community here and today
you can see that a lot of professionals
being united not just northern france
but normandy and brittany as well it's a
national movement and i think it's a
great great thing that despite all the
problems that we're experiencing at the
moment there is a lot of support within
the community and from the government
and from public opinion as well
you're disrupting uh freight into the uk
i mean do you really think that's the
right way to go about pressurizing the
british government into granting these
extra fishing licenses we want to be
heard that's the thing we really want to
be heard we want to go and react and so
far you know 11 months after we were
promised licenses there was nothing
happening so i think that's the last
solution we waited until the last minute
really because before we we're not going
to do that we're going to wait we're not
we don't want to interfere we don't want
to do anything wrong because there were
a lot of negotiations was like we're not
going to interfere but nice now we've
had enough really so
that's the last resource and we hope
that we're going to be heard and we hope
all we want the license is if we get the
license we're going to stop that's all
you hope to be heard but do you think
the current tensions between the uk and
france obviously we saw pretty patel
being disinvited to this uh conference
on sunday on a wide range of different
issues do you think it will make it more
difficult for you to eventually get some
sort of agreement so that we don't have
to have these sort of protests we're
kind of desperate to be honest uh and
we're the victim of political strategy
and guiding aids
we don't want to be victim anymore we
just want to be respected so that's why
we're organizing that
okay benoit thank you very much for
joining us here today uh the fishermen
here say that this protest blocking the
euro tunnel entrance is going to
continue today at least for a couple of
hours now the eu has given britain a
deadline of december the 10th to try and
come to some sort of new deal britain
says it is respecting the post uh brexit
deal because all of this emanated uh
since the uh the departure of the uk
from the european union but uh the
fishermen here today have said um while
this protest may only last for a few
hours they will reserve the right to
take similar action if progress isn't
made on the granting of these fishing
licenses to french fishermen to operate
in british territorial waters